what's going on guys this is Rob and I
know how much you all love crazy
displays of power in Marvel Comics Godly
beings fighting Godly beings and this
video is gonna have it you're gonna see
a just ridiculous displays of power over
the course of of this comic so let's
just get into it right so what this does
is it initially opens up with Dr Doom
attacking the molecule man Owen Reese
for those people who are unfamiliar with
the molecule man and unfamiliar with the
power this guy has this guy could snap
his fingers and Earth would just cease
to exist or the universe would cease to
exist this guy's level of power is so
extreme that in secret Wars 2 which was
the follow-up to the original Secret
Wars in 1984. this guy and the beyonder
fought to a standstill and their impact
right the impact of their punches and
their hits were so intense they sent
shock waves throughout the Multiverse
right now we'll kind of clarify the role
of the beyonder and all that kind of
stuff over the course of this comic
because what we're going to be doing
here and really the reason why we're
doing this in the first place place is
that we know that the beyonder is in
some capacity supposed to be involved in
in Avengers cane Dynasty and Secret Wars
we don't really know what his role will
be the rumor is that he's going to be a
variant of Kang I don't know it's all
just conjecture no one knows anything
for sure but because it all might be
true
we already covered Secret Wars in 1984.
we covered Secret Wars 2 in 1986 and
1987. this is The Unofficial Secret Wars
3 that took place that kind of wrapped
up the plot threads from Secret Wars 1
and 2 and then of course we already
covered Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and
New Avengers along with Secret Wars in
2015 and then we did Defenders Beyond
we've covered a lot of stuff that dealt
with the beyonders and so we're going to
compile all of this along with a few
things that we haven't done yet we're
going to put all that into a singular
great big huge video and send that out
there for you guys to watch so you can
become experts on the beyonders for in
however long it takes for you to finish
that video so the thing about this is
with Dr Doom having overpowered the
molecule man the only reason he's able
to do this is because his attack comes
fast and Swift that if the molecule
man's not prepared for it he's just like
anybody else right like he can be
overcome by someone like Dr Doom now the
other reason why Dr Doom is able to do
this is because the plot demands it
let's be honest with ourselves guys even
if demolish virtual man was taken by
surprise by Dr Doom the level of power
this guy has it wouldn't matter right so
this was just kind of Steve engelhardt
just kind of being like I mean you know
reasons just go along with it comic book
logic but this whole story is actually
going to change the power of molecule
man and the beyonder in a way that
honestly people weren't the biggest fans
of but once this guy's defeated of
course we get the classic Doctor Doom
monologue where he says like look at the
street rabble Flinch though they know
nothing of what I've done exiled from my
homeland he was actually defeated by his
son Christoph Bernard and kicked out of
his own country which is kind of crazy
right stripped of the Diplomatic
Immunity which once shielded me am I not
still Doom woe to the common policeman
who attempts to subject me to American
law woe to America
it's one of the things I love about
Doctor Doom Dr Doom man I love him
because of just like his one-liners and
stuff the guy is just as much one of the
deadliest forces in the universe as he
is Aegis Limitless repository of humor I
love Doctor Doom
I love Doctor Doom but here's the other
thing too right so what you guys
obviously see here as we're going
through this is you see this chick that
looks like the thing right like she's
just kind of big she doesn't really have
all the rocky stuff that's Sharon
Ventura she sucks she hasn't been
relevant in Marvel Comics in like 40
years she's she hasn't mattered in
forever and even when this was going on
she still didn't matter but the thing
about this is that Sharon Ventura was
just the attempt by Marvel to give like
Ben Graham his own love interest that
was comparable to him because up until
this point he was basically married to a
blind girl or at least was dating a
blind girl named Alicia Masters and so
it's just it's one of those things that
kind of goes on but Dr Doom of course
invades four Freedom's Plaza right the
home of the Fantastic Four at this point
in time the whole reason why he does
this is to gain access to a portal that
they have in order to reach the realm or
the the dimension of the beyonder or at
least the beyonders themselves now the
whole reason why this is going on and
the whole reason why Doom's doing this
and even has any information about this
in the first place is because cousin
Fantastic Four issues 316 and 317
leading into this comic and the next one
three AI 318 and 319 is that the
Fantastic Four which Reed and Susan are
kind of off to in their own thing that's
why you don't see him here but the
Fantastic Four had learned about an
alien race called the nawali and while
we as as the reader didn't really get a
whole lot of information about them all
we knew is they operated as agents of
the beyonders and this is the first time
when you actually hear the beyonders
referred to as a group as opposed to a
singular entity but of course Doctor
Doom trying to get to that location
right trying to get to the realm of the
beyonders we'll consolidate and make
make sense of all that stuff by the time
we finish this video The Fantastic Four
of course try to stop him right now of
course they're basically defeated by Dr
Doom who just takes off into the portal
himself the Fantastic Four bored a
vessel and they follow after him but
they're also doing that because at the
same time they want to know what's going
on with the beyonders and the new Wally
if for no other reason than to gain
enough information to prepare for the
potential Return of the Beyond because
the last time that guy was on Earth he
wiped out pretty much all the cosmic
entities and he almost destroyed
everything in creation there was
actually a point where he killed
mistress death so nobody in the universe
could die and and I wouldn't say he
killed her I would say he just snapped
his fingers and she just ceased to exist
that's how powerful that guy was of
course he ended up bringing her back and
everything was kind of set to right and
the fight between himself and the
molecule man but the bigger point that
I'm making here is that as they make
their way through what is in effect the
Multiverse the first stop is the
negative zone now the negative zone is
not overly important to this particular
story here they pass through it I mean
they fight blastar who's one of the guys
who's in the negative Zone he doesn't
really matter like he literally shows up
he attacks him it almost destroys their
vessel right Doctor Doom saves them and
that's kind of the way in which Steve
engelhardt explains how Dr Doom ends up
joining the Fantastic Four temporarily
on their journey to figure out what's
going on with the beyonders and so
following this things get really really
cool because what they start doing after
passing through the negative zone is
they actually start passing through all
these different universes that exist out
there the first Universe they come
across is a universe where everything is
completely dark there's no light there
whatsoever now you could make an
argument and I imagine this is something
that will Marvel Marvel will probably
end up doing later on down the line This
is where null the Symbiote God resides
or at least you know a place where he
just kind of hangs out the reason why I
say that is that in Marvel Comics Noel
was a being that existed really when
really before the current Universe came
into existence when the celestial showed
up and started creating life it pissed
him off right bringing light to uh to a
dark place and so the result of this is
that he waged war against the celestials
he was kind of banished to a degree so
Donnie Cates in them I imagine probably
borrowed from this the next Universe
they cross through is a universe
completely and totally housed by the mad
celestials you could make a credible
argument that during Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four run this was the universe
where the celestials came from the Mad
celestials who basically tried to
destroy everything in existence right
who conquered their own verse and then
try to spread outward into other
universes so again this is why I say it
looks like Jonathan Hickman borrowed a
lot of stuff from this particular story
but of course as they they continue to
make their way through the Multiverse
they end up coming to what looks like
back home right like literally a place
where there's clouds and there's a sun
and there's buildings and stuff like
that and in fact Johnny Storm gets
pissed he was like dude you just brought
us right back where we started we went
on this whole mission for no reason and
you were the one that said you could
guide us to where we needed to be and
the response of Doctor Doom is no we're
in the right place and he calls the
beyonder out and it turns out not only
is the beyonder basically the sun he's
like you're all dead like I'm gonna kill
you all
and he just immediately starts attacking
everybody now what's kind of funny about
this is that this was being written and
done in a way in order to make the story
credible or at least to give the story
some some measure of longevity because
they're literally in a universe that is
the beyonder right like everything in
this universe is the beyonder right the
land the the sky and the Sun the whole
nine yards he is in effect God so if he
wanted to he could snap his fingers and
they would simply just cease to exist
but in order to tell a compelling story
and to kind of get to why all of this is
happening in the first place you
basically see the beyonder fighting
against a Fantastic Four in a
conventional form now the thing about
this is that Doctor Doom approaches the
beyonder and instead of doing what he
intended to do or at least what he did
do in the original Secret Wars from 1984
which was attacked Beyond her and then
sees his power for himself that what Dr
Doom actually wants is to be made whole
the reason for this is because at a
previous point in time in the Fantastic
Four comics that Dr Doom had actually
been killed or at least was believed to
have been killed by tarach the Tamer who
was basically the main enemy of Galactus
I'm sorry the uh a one-time Herald of
Galactus but the idea here is that in
his defeat and with his body destroyed
he sent his Consciousness into the mind
of a normal human being who was watching
the event unfold following that he
basically held his family hostage until
he could find a way to bring himself
back and while he did do that
momentarily right which is to say
Gathering the the various armors that he
needed and so on and so forth he's not
actually Dr Doom at this point in time
meaning he's not his full self not only
that there were huge chunks of his
memory that are missing and so what he
wants to be honored to do is to
basically use his power to make Doctor
Doom whole so that Doctor Doom can be
back to his normal level of power he can
have all of his memories intact and he
can in turn Face Off against his son
Christoph Bernard and basically seize
control of latviria again the truth
about why Doctor Doom is doing this is
because if he's made whole what he would
be able to do is actually seize the the
the beyonder's power and then maintain
that level of power and essentially
become ruler of the universe Dr Doom
doing Doctor Doom things but as this
happens and when the beyonder is about
to Grant this request we end up getting
the arrival of two of the most powerful
beings in the history of Marvel Comics
cubic and the shaper of Worlds now this
is this I know it seems like you guys
are probably like who like what like
like what is it Guardians of the Galaxy
I'm Star-Lord who like that kind of
thing right
right I'm gonna make all this make sense
don't worry I'm not gonna leave you
hanging but the fight between these guys
is immense right like as soon as this
happens cubic in the shaper of Worlds
immediately step in and they basically
start to attack the beyonder now what's
crazy about this and this is where we
start to get into this murky territory
of Marvel arbitrarily just kind of
changing things cubic and the shape
worlds are able to overpower the
beyonder traditionally it's not that way
the level of power he was shown to have
in the in secret Wars 2 and to a degree
in the first Secret Wars no way would
would cubic and the shaper of Worlds be
able to overpower this guy but such as
it is they're able to do that right and
the reason why we'll actually become
apparent here in a little bit but at the
end of it all as they attack what ends
up happening is the molecule man Owen
Reese is brought to the entire location
by volcano basically his girl a portal
is open and the two of them are brought
here because the molecule man starts to
realize what's going on right he kind of
piece the piece everything together on
his own off panel but he realized Dr
Doom going after the beyonder and asking
the beyonder to quote unquote make him
whole what give Dr Doom the intelligence
he needs to seize control of the
beyonder's power and be able to maintain
the beyonder's power and so that's when
you have the shaper of Worlds cubic the
molecule man and all of them basically
attacking uh the beyonder now in the
midst of all that volcano is killed but
again this is the level of the molecule
man where he basically just restores her
to life and then places them inside a
protective Dome where nothing can harm
them right they're literally just there
watching this massive conflict unfold
but at the end of the day whether
beyonder is more or less subdued even if
only momentarily it allows the story to
start moving into Exposition it allows
us to focus on what's actually taking
place here and so one of the things that
we learn or at least as is explained of
course once the Revelation comes out
about doctor Doom's intention and so on
and so forth Ben Grimm steps up and says
look the only reason why we're here is
because we're trying to understand
what's going on with the beyonders what
are they why are they doing what they do
what's going on here how does the new
Wally and Earth Savage land right
basically that kind of jungle
environment that houses dinosaurs and
all that kind of stuff that was created
by or at least engineered by the new
Wally what does all this have to do how
does it all tie together and do we need
to be worried about the beyonders
returning and so what the shaper of
world says is somewhere in the negative
Zone The Mad conjunction of Realms
around us is a lightless universe they
dwell there no one has ever seen them
and no one ever will but they see all of
us and they wish us well they want us to
grow to become as they are now as
anybody knows from Reading Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers
going into Secret Wars this is actually
not the case that the beyonders wanted
to wipe out the Multiverse they were the
exact opposite of the explanation that
the shaper of Worlds gets here now the
question that you'd probably be asking
yourself is okay like did something
change did their motivations change the
reality is that this explanation of the
intentions and the motivations of the
beyonders was simply just changed by
Jonathan Hickman to fit the story that
he was telling that's all it was right
but the shaper of world says you
understand it is not accurate to
describe the beyonders as beings who do
things in a chronological order they
transcend all such labels simply let us
say as convenience that at some distant
time they became aware of the universe
containing the Earth they could never
enter the universe or any Universe
outside of their own they are so be
Beyond us that they must operate
entirely through agents now many of us
in this universe have learned that Earth
has a special combination of equalities
which breeds super beings though many of
us have sought to learn why the answer
remains unknown to us but in our distant
past the beyonders determined to find
out now one of the things to understand
here is that at the time this story was
written a lot of the work regarding the
celestials modifying the genes of
humanity that had largely been done but
one of the things that was going on is
there was a lot of bickering behind the
scenes in Marvel as far as like the work
Jack Kirby was doing Jack Kirby by this
point in time had basically when he was
essentially gone but when he crafted the
eternals and said the eternals had
modified the genes of early man that's
basically what led to people having
powers and so on and so forth that it
really just existed to explain the
eternals and the deviants it hadn't been
co-opted yet to explain why superheroes
have powers now during Grant Morrison's
run when he was specifically covered
every new X-Men and the weapons programs
as well as some of the stories that came
before it that's when Marvel started
invoking the idea of the celestials
modifying the genes of Baseline humans
so that some future point in time they
would develop Powers the easiest
explanation is that would lead to
mutants but it was also used as an
unofficial explanation for why Steve
Rogers could receive the super soldier
serum and instead of like dying due to
the serum's effects could be blasted
with different forms of light rays and
then become Captain America but again
what he says here is that the beyonders
contacted the alien race called nuwali
through a radical cue and that the
beyonders offered them gold to create a
Game Preserve on Earth many have asked
why but the answer is apparent the game
preserved stocked and restocked over
Millennia was a laboratory of evolution
it may be said that the beyonders wanted
to experiment eons later they used their
knowledge to evolve the fortescuans to
act as their agents by Nature rather
than for reward for gold given such
parents it's Little Wonder the
fortescuans seek to limit their contact
with others or go mad so easily but he
says with their commentary flybys
meaning they flew by looking like comets
they have discovered much that was
useful to the beyonders concerning
beings on different worlds they showed
the beyonders that what drives all
beings is desire for what they lack and
so this was significant in terms of how
they really explain the form and
function of the honors because again
what they said is to be honors have a
level of power that just because they're
so extreme they're so beyond everything
they can't function or exist inside of
our universe now it's a very throwaway
kind of hand wavy explanation because
you would think of being or at least a
group of beings with the power of God
would be able to just enter in and out
of universes as they saw fit but for any
number of reasons they couldn't at this
point in time now during Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers he
corrected that he was like actually they
can and when they came into the
Multiverse they basically killed all the
cosmic entities including the Living
Tribunal it was really more Jonathan
Hickman reworking this explanation to
say the beyonders don't see themselves
as beings that need to come down to the
level of individuals who exist in a
normal Universe right they're beyond
that insofar as we're way more powerful
than that why would we waste our time on
that kind of thing right we've got
bigger fish to fry and more important
things to focus on and so in response to
that the beyonders contacted the new
Wally and said you will be the ones that
will travel around the universe and
basically create life on different
worlds and so this was an explanation
for why life exists on different planets
across the cosmos does it fly in direct
contradiction with the nature of the
celestials yes but this is one of those
instances when Marvel just didn't really
offer any way to correct that at the
time this story was written the idea was
that if the new Wally were going to be
traveling around and creating life they
didn't have time to like monitor it and
so what they did is they had the
fortescuins created so that the
fortescuans could basically fly by
different world and monitor those worlds
and report back to the new Ali who in
turn would report their findings to the
beyonders and that the beyonders
themselves would basically just kind of
monitor their experiments on Earth and
just see how they could help the
evolution of different races because
they wanted those races to become as
capable as the beyonders themselves
again the beyonders were approaching
this from a place of positivity right
from a place of trying to help groups
better themselves as opposed to what
Jonathan Hickman did which was basically
blow up the Multiverse and so what this
does is it goes into an explanation
about the nature of the cosmic cubes
specifically about the shaper of Worlds
and about comic because what they what
the shaper says is the beyonders now
moved to a third phase in their inter in
their actions or interactions with us
they gave us the Cosmic Cube and so what
happened is the beyonders basically
modified seemingly reality in such a way
so that every 34 years or 32 years and
four months a rift would open that would
Grant a person access to the power of
the Beyond verse where the beyonders
reside and that if a person was present
when that Rift opened they could
literally draw that power out and it
would shape itself into the form of a
cube where it would go into a stasis
Cube that had been previously
constructed and that would become the
Cosmic Cube It's the explanation of why
Cosmic cubes are so powerful because
they literally contain the power of the
beyonders which can basically do
anything and so what this meant is that
at least when it comes to the shaper of
Worlds these are two instances when the
power of the beyonders have been
captured in the form of a Cosmic Cube
but they basically became sentient they
they essentially evolved Beyond simply
just being a cube housing power and
developed its own mind so think of it
like Skynet from Terminator right except
from instead of wiping everything out
they just kind of flew off into the
sunset and did their own thing and
that's basically it but it's why these
two are also so immensely powerful
because what they do is they explain the
nature of the beyonder itself and even
molecule man once you start starts to
realize what's going on using his
multiversal awareness he offers his own
explanation and so what he says is that
when it comes to the beyonder the
beyonder simply came into existence
because when the molecule man was
initially conducting his experiment or
doing his work that led to him granting
his power being given his powers in the
first place that what he had
inadvertently done was rip a hole in
reality to the Beyond verse that it
wasn't created by the beyonders and it
wasn't supposed to happen but in doing
so half of that power went into Owen
Reese because there was no Cosmic Cube
for that power to go into and the other
half of that power went out into the
cosmos and became sentient so the
beyonder is not actually a member of the
race of beyonders instead the beyonder
is the power of the beyonders which
became sentient so that's why he stands
alone that's why there's such a huge
difference between the beyonders and the
beyonder and so as this explanation
comes to bear it's Marvel telling us
that what's going on here is molecule a
molecule man Owen Reese and the beyonder
are two sides of the same coin but the
beyonder is actually more powerful than
the molecule man that's how it is that
the beyonder was actually able to
overpower the molecule man during Secret
Wars 2. It's just sure they share a
similar source of power but 40 of all
that power that came out of the Beyond
verse forty percent run into molecule
man 60 became the beyonder but if he had
to assign ratios in order to make it
make sense and so what this does is it
explains why the beyonder has never
actually fulfilled a purpose that the
beyonder wanted a mission when it
initially emerged in like Secret Wars 1
and during Secret Wars 2 it simply just
desired right that's all it was like I
desire I desire to know things right I
just desire stuff but nobody really knew
what it actually desired and the reason
why is because it wasn't fulfilling its
purpose the role of the beyonder was to
fulfill the purpose of other people
right it's designed to Grant other
people's wishes to make other people's
dreams come true not its own that's not
the role that it's supposed to play and
and so in failing to fulfill that
purpose by just going out and doing its
own thing it never truly felt satisfied
and when when this whole explanation is
given to the beyonder partly by cubic or
by comic in the shaper of Worlds as well
as by the molecule man Owen Reese that's
when it starts to realize okay then the
only way for our purpose to actually be
fulfilled is for myself and Owen Reese
to merge right to become whole to become
what we should have been when the
initial experiment by molecule man took
place that granted both of us our powers
in the first place that created me and
granted the molecule man his abilities
and so what they end up doing is
basically merging into a singular Cosmic
Cube and that in time that Cosmic Cube
stands a high likelihood of the coming
sentient now before it does Dr Doom does
what Dr Doom does which is basically try
to seize control of the Cosmic Cube of
course he's defeated right off the bat
by by Kavik and and the in the shaper of
Worlds and that's basically the end of
him but it is a cool thing right it is a
cool moment where Dr Doom tries to like
become God again because that's what Dr
Doom always does but at the end of the
day once the cube is created and the
molecule man and the beyonder
essentially cease to exist they just
exist in this Cube form everybody's
whisked back to four Freedom's Plaza and
then Dr Doom who is in effect basically
made whole to a degree goes back to his
land to try to take back control of
latviria from his son Christoph Bernard
and that's it right that's basically how
it ends now in the future molecule man
would actually end up coming back but he
wouldn't be as powerful as he was before
right this was a story whenever you hear
people talk about how there is a prereq
con molecule man and post retcon
molecule man meaning he was more
powerful before than he is now this is
the moment when that happened this is
when they reduced the power of the
molecule man Owen Reese and the story
they used to do it so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end thank you all for watching and
I will catch you all later
peace